you welcome to this video on playing
grand master mega zedzee from australia
um can I have a look here DM Grand
Master Zhong yuan Sal probably
butchering this pronunciation yup is
2534 here so very high rated we got a
sloth let's see you soon the classical
Slav accepted on c4 yeah there's III and
95 I'm going for e3 this is so
relatively simple to play white
completes this development and term goes
form e form I can play you for here as a
parsec he takes on c3 it takes only form
so he takes it but White's compensation
is then the fact that the bishop only
three prevents a short castling and yeah
non-catholic well certainly and possible
is a risky business ok so how to
continue
yeah not easy to save
curtain c3 is hanging and maybe 96 as a
possible possible
okay but 96 I can take on e cig so this
is not really an issue okay maybe
protects III for the moment okay this is
a theoretical position so it would be
nice if I actually had some concrete
knowledge but I don't I don't have it ok
a success as a weird move what is the
point of this ok don't really understand
because he he basically needs to UM to
Castle long and how are you going to do
that with a 6 plate I don't know okay if
I go night h form intending to take
maybe this is a good idea it's not clear
what his responses yeah this is possible
but not not a very attractive move they
go f3 now 96 take on e6 hmm and yes it's
possible
96 at a g6 and where else I mean 95 s as
possible but what are you doing on g5
okay at least him he got got his King
out of the center it's still pretty
pretty bad position to bishops against
two nights or so is a problem but it's
nothing nothing concrete yet sorry got a
bit of a sore throat here um g6 was
hanging this was the idea okay maybe
night f4 but I want I want to play
rookie you want anyway exchanging rocks
is a general not a bad idea in this
seventh position he also had rookie
three arm or something like that so need
to get need to get this out of the
picture and now i'm attending just
rookie one
yeah the position is excellent I'm only
significantly down on time one minute
fifty
yeah well this is certainly not playable
I mean cannot believe that matter you
never know okay okay the time is of
course the the issue okay it's night on
g2 should i play h 4s 6s sick as it
looks but it prevents g5
ya know threaten you look at four yeah
that's completely busted for black but
one minute he's got no way to prevent
regret for
hmm
now Queen 85 coming it's not so easy for
a technical point of view because I've
got this pretty open King position
check
check
check yeah it's not easy with 30 seconds
check yeah you could just take on c3
what is just playing this game very
badly but okay what can you do you will
win on time
check I'm warning ya hmm it's just
promoting white here's an i was just far
too slow of course I must win this he
played this so horribly but okay it's um
it's not not entirely easy how to make
that how to make that I clean victory
here maybe just the bishop to be to to
block that it's not it's not so easy I
mean I allowed him to enter with the
Queen and this is probably a already
making it very difficult now now it's
just um just not so easy around here
like ass has got some plane he's so
shouldn't win but it's a it's very
difficult with this open King in 40
seconds when I mean like like is in very
bad shape anyway Andrew takes this this
night air for brookey for is just it's
just completely unplayable and and black
him like his black is gone here maybe
it's um I could have played this some
could have played this somewhat more
convincingly i'm not i'm not so sure i
can take a form but this looks far more
logical to me uh yeah I can play Bishop
d Sixers won one possibility okay but
this is probably all right yeah what can
you it is winning i mean i cannot i can
look for more clear clearer wins but
it's just just doesn't make much sense i
mean
but soon you can only get get one point
per game and it was it was another
actually but yeah the open tune is the
problem maybe I should play rock f2 I
mean I saw the smooth but each flower
looked looked strong but it's probably
better it's probably better Luke f2 is
probably the better move when I'm
getting getting the night anyway but I
thought age 45 would be more aggressive
but ok and at the end it was a matter of
the clock alright thanks for watching